oh yes we start so we have theorized
convinced quantum EcoSport organization
thanks Michael thanks to the organizers
for inviting me here I will be talking
about some work that I have been doing
for the last couple of years there will
be some things which from a year or two
ago some things that we just finished
last month and some things which are not
finished yet so a little bit of
everything so I guess what I have been
trying to understand the last couple of
years is kind of try to ask a very
simple question well it's not very it's
simple to post the question but not very
simple to answer the question which is
what will be the applications of quantum
computers right so obviously we can say
that let's build them first and then
we'll figure out what to do with them so
I'm very happy with that answer but I
still I want to understand at least
where should we be looking to find these
applications right so we had talks about
general quantum chemistry about
simulation of many body physics but
since I have no idea about chemistry and
no idea about many body physics I will
look at you know something that I might
have some later success in looking at
which is optimization machine learning
ok all right so I guess the result that
kind of jump-started this this this area
I'm sure there were results also before
that but the one that kind of made
people more interested in this was the
result by Haro has hit him and lloyd
from 2009 which is the famous HSL
algorithm ok so they're quite a few ways
of stating this algorithm one way is to
say that you know quantum computers can
solve systems of linear equations then
obviously you will have Scott to say
that you have to read the fine print
here I made it in red not fine but there
are many kind of things that you have to
be careful when you say that we know how
to solve systems of linear equations the
first thing is to say that the solution
that you get from the quantum algorithm
is not the solution to the linear system
is a quantum state that corresponds to
the classical solution it gives you a
vector that corresponds to the classical
solution the second thing you need to
understand is that
this Afghan which could be exponentially
file faster in some cases but actually
the running time is kind of a
complicated thing that you need to
really understand how it works for your
specific problem and the third one is
that you do have to assume that you have
some sort of quantum access to your data
okay so the many different ways of
saying what kind of quantum axes you
need so we will see a little bit more
but I think Stacy also discussed this
yesterday about different types of
quantum access to figure data
okay so the good thing is that there was
a lot of you know excitement about this
result the excitement to be honest came
more from not necessarily from the
people who are in academia but with
people for in in big companies so I'm
just stating I'm just citing here
something from a quantum machine
learning workshop during the Knicks 2015
that was organized by Google and
Microsoft and they wrote that it opens
the possibility of dramatic speed ups
for machine learning tasks richer models
for data sets and more natural settings
for learning into inference so that was
a few years ago so I really try to
understand what are these dramatic speed
ups and in where can we actually see
these these things I do want to make one
small point for the more complexity
theory people is that basically this
problem like solving the system's a
linear equation is a bit could be
complete problem in some sense so kind
of you can see that this is what quantum
computers can actually do right
I don't remember anyone remembers and
what reductions you can get the bqp
completeness I think it's it
straightforward there may be a big
reduction
alright so I want to start with a few
remarks about quantum machine learning
somehow I don't necessarily feel that
you should all agree with them but at
least this is how I see things ok so to
me if you want to really get some
exponential savings in this this area
you will need to compute the quantum
computer which is like a big quantum
computer and you will need to have some
quantum access to your data ok so your
quantum axis could be because your data
is really quantum yeah I said that not
everyone will agree it's possible for
you to have an exponential speed-up over
simulating that because implementation
of the quantum model could be complete
so depends on some problems depend on
the input yes and you're absolutely
right but if the prediction is you know
hard so let me say that I'm trying to
look at problems that are already that
people already kind of interested to
solve like I'm sure you can come up with
things that you can do exponentially
faster without having what I claim here
so I agree with you but for the things
that I will discuss and you know the
subset of quantum machine learning that
I'm more interested in I don't know how
to get exponential saving somehow if you
don't have some sort of quantum access
to your to your data right ok the second
thing is that I kind of find it that
it's kind of the most overhyped and
underestimated area of quantum
information at this point so obviously
this is a contradiction but it's not a
contradiction because you know it's a
disjoint set of people who ever hype it
and disjoint set of people who
underestimate it so you know both can
at the same time somehow now let's okay
let's over/under high bids so that's my
god no but really what I need to
understand is you know there are people
who say that oh you can do everything
you know there were other people who say
that you can do nothing so what I'm
trying to understand is basically where
we are in the scale of you know happen
you know nothing is possible I know so
ask me again at the end of the talk
maybe you'll get a better feeling of
where I am or then we can discuss it
right somewhere in between okay
I haven't said that I still think that
it's one of the most convincing regions
that like I can find at least for myself
to actually say that yes we should
really spend all this effort and time to
actually try to build quantum computers
like big scale quantum computers right
I'm sure there are other reasons to do
that but for me being able to solve
optimization problems that everyone kind
of tries to solve in practice or machine
learning tasks that people actually
really want to solve and they're getting
to the to the limits of their of the HPC
capacities it would be a good thing like
so to me that this makes it the whole
effort of building from the computer is
quite an interesting one okay so very
briefly what what basically says she
also explained yesterday so I guess
every time you want to have a some sort
of quantum machine learning or at least
the type that I'm looking at they're
kind of two steps the first step is that
there is this data that kind of appears
or somehow you make some experiment you
get this data you have to do something
with your data like the simplest thing
is that you can store it classically so
somehow you need to spend time linear on
the size of the data to actually even
see the data and write it down right so
when we want to say that you have
quantum access to the data
I want to assume the following that I
allow you to do some to use some sort of
data structure which could be something
a little bit more elaborate than just
writing the data one after the other so
you can use some sort of array or tree
structure or something like that but I
don't want to basically pick up with
everything and then try to tell you that
they can do good
because I spend all my time doing the
pre-processing right so I want to be
able to store to update and to delete
any element of this data in poly
logarithmic time okay
and then what I call quantum access to
this data is basically been able to do
quantum queries in superposition this is
exactly what you need for all kind of
query algorithms how is your difficult
this is to do well it kind of depends it
could be that a a IJ is a very simple
function of I comma J do you have a very
simple circuit to actually do it so
sometimes it's very easy sometimes it's
less easy so then you have to work more
okay
and also there are many other models is
the sparse model they're very more
loaded and then the second step of this
is that once you have pre process your
data and you have your data there you
need to do some computation to this data
for example you need to learn some
property of this data right so it's on
this step that the running time of the
quantum algorithm can be actually more
efficient than the classical one right
somehow we are not saving anything here
in fact we are just saying that only you
can at most pend poly logarithmic time
or right but somehow it's here that we
want to have an advantage right for
example classically you might try to do
some computation that that is like cubic
on the dimension of your data here you
would like something which plans much
better than cubical the dimension of the
data okay good okay so I will give a
very briefly explanation about the first
example that we try to come up with so
the idea was can we get some example of
something that people actually really
want to solve and figure out a quantum
algorithm that I can prove something
about the complex to this algorithm okay
so I guess this problem is the Netflix
challenge or the recommendation systems
the problem is very simple I give you a
matrix of users and products you have
some knowledge about this matrix because
some user bought some product and they
said thumbs up or thumbs down okay so
you have some elements of this matrix
you have a lot of question marks about
this matrix because you don't know if
this user will like this product or not
okay
the whole point is to figure out where
are these good products for the user
like a user comes into the system you
need to be able to recommend a good
product right okay so I guess it's it's
an application that Netflix or Amazon
want to solve maybe not ask but anyways
so there is a very clear mathematical
problem that comes out of this which is
what it was called matrix reconstruction
so maybe basically what is the main way
that we we knew how to do this classical
is to say that okay I'm gonna take this
matrix and somehow I'll find a way to
reconstruct all the missing element of
this matrix in a way that this
reconstructed matrix should be close to
the real matrix that I don't know right
and then what will I do well if if this
user comes into the system I will try I
will look at this line I will figure out
whether the the high valued elements and
I'm going to recommend an element
regular right so the first thing we have
to do is to realize that the matrix
deconstruction is not really what you
want to do which is kind of overkill in
the sense that if you want to find a
high element on the matrix you don't
necessarily have to reconstruct the
entire matrix right because
reconstructing the entire matrix will
will obviously take time which is linear
on the size of this matrix because at
least you have to write it down right so
the first thing to to notice is that if
you're manage to sample from this matrix
it's good enough in the sense that
you're going to sample high valued
elements like the ones of the matrix
right so this was the first thing that
we had to do kind of change a bit the
classic and the problem that we were
trying to solve the second step was to
to kind of reduce this problem into some
sort of linear algebra procedure and
this was kind of basically how to do
with estimating the singular values of
this matrix and then we can use the
algorithms that can show that you can
have quantum algorithm the singular
value estimation which could be
exponentially faster sometimes so we
also had to show that whether this time
the specific thing here you can actually
have exponential faster algorithms or
not right so sorry
so basically using this fact we could
show that one two computers could
provide competitive recommendation
systems exponentially faster than on
classical algo
so what did we have to do for this well
first of all we have to improve the
linear algebra that we knew so far
because we knew how to do linear algebra
like matrix inversion or matrix
multiplication for sparse matrices this
is what the h HL and the other
algorithms could do what we needed to do
it is not for sparse matrices but also
for low rank matrices why low rank
matrices because the assumption that
that you have in recommendation systems
is that basically this matrix is well
approximated by a low rank matrix okay
so we have to first figure out ways of
doing this kind of linear algebraic
computation efficiently for lowering
matrices
okay and the running time that we got is
something which is per logarithmic on
the dimension of the matrix which is
good and then as you know there are some
factors in front of that where the
algorithm the running time of the
algorithm depends polynomially so if
these factors are very big for example
if there is if it is like the dimension
then you are not really doing something
right so for example if this factor was
the sparsity of the matrix then the
sparsity of this matrix is not very it's
actually very big is like the dimension
so you wouldn't get an exponential
speed-up but since we managed to get
this kind of procedures for lower rank
matrices what we managed to put here is
actually the rank of the matrix and the
assumption is that the rank of the
matrix is much smaller than of the
dimension of the matrix and this is not
our assumption this is the assumption of
classical recommendation system okay
good so this was just one example in
theory this algorithm works in practice
I have no idea if it's going to work
like I really don't know what kind of
accuracy how well your recommendations
are going to be or really what kind of
running time you would have in practice
I also don't have data to try to
understand if this actually runs well or
not so if there are people from Facebook
or the Chinese Facebook or Amazon or
Chinese Amazon and they want to give me
data I'm very happy to try and see if
this actually works
okay so then we try to look at some
something else because we solved a very
specific problem the question that we
had is that can we get some sort of
general methods that you can use in
machine learning or optimization so what
is kind of the method 101 that you
you people use in order to do
optimization it's kind of gradient
descent okay so what is the whole point
of gradient descent you start you kind
of guess a solution
you kind of look around to see what is
the best way to proceed you kind of take
it a step you go to an X solution you
check if it is a good solution or not if
not you find the direction that it's
good for you to go that way you continue
until you end up somewhere where it's
kind of a local minimum you are around
there you go out for this okay so it's a
very high-level explanation but this is
kind of what I tell you the methods do
you start with an initial solution we
figure out how to update your solution
after a few steps you have to prove that
you converge to something which is very
close to a good point right okay so the
first order that is called gradient
descent the second order that are called
interior point methods so what we
managed to do for that is we managed to
have some sort of quantum version of
gradient descent but it only works for
for the case where the gradient is
actually simple function to compute min
which is a linear function okay so the
only thing we can solve is a gradient
descent where at every step
basically you're solving a linear system
okay so now you can say that if if what
I do at every step I solve a linear
system then basically you can write down
your entire problem as a big linear
system and you can use h HL or whatever
algorithm you want to solve your linear
system altogether
so you don't really have to do gradient
descent if you're basically having a
linear linear gradient but somehow in
practice is much better for you to do
this gradient descent even if you're
having linear update than actually try
to solve a very big linear system and
I'll tell you why the first one okay
sorry
I'll tell you about this but the reason
is for example if I want to do a linear
system in a very big matrix I would have
to have some quantum access to this very
big matrix right if I'm trying to solve
the same linear system but with some
sort of gradient descent or better with
this stochastic gradient descent what
people do in practice is that they don't
look at the entire matrix at once they
just chop the matrix into small
Dutch's and they try and they solve
linear systems on the smaller
dimensional matrix which means that
every time I want to use my Kyurem I
only have to to quantumly have access to
a much smaller matrix and the entire
matrix so it depends on how so if you so
the idea is that usually okay in many
cases your matrix is like this because
you have many points this is the number
of points and these are like the
dimension of your points so in cases
where something is like this what you do
is that instead of solving the entire
linear system once you just cut the
thing like this and you solve linear
systems you update you do the same right
now how small this is there are cases
where basically you do it line by line
okay the idea is that you don't have to
go all the way down because you have too
much point too many points that live in
small dimension we don't have to see the
entire matrix but you can load it one
after the other you see what I mean like
my question is what how big is my
superposition that I need
how big a quantum query in superposition
do I have to make like at every point
and at every point you need to have a
superposition of these points then you
see what I mean so you don't have to
have a coherent superposition of all
these points which means that your
current would be ten to the twelve you
can split it into smaller chunks and
have it's much easier to have a thousand
QMS of a thousand cubed that molecule
above a million cubits because it's much
easier to because it
that you do know I mean you do know that
the state on six cubits it's much easier
than a state on one hundred cubits
somehow right okay sure so in my opinion
I think it's easier but maybe it's not
you're right okay but all right cool the
other thing that we had to do for this
paper is actually further improve this
linear algebra procedures so now they
don't only work for low rank matrices
but they also work for other type of
matrices that you get some different
kind of guarantee on the running time
okay all right so I was kind of very
impressed with Robins talk yesterday of
how clean everything was so I try to
have one slide where I try to explain
maybe in my way on how to do quantum
linear algebra somehow okay so this is
the one slide that kind of basically
here are some things that you may want
to do you have a matrix a in a vector X
you want to output some sort of
operation on these two things like you
want to output a times X or a minus one
times X or you might want to project X
onto the top eigen space of this matrix
or some sort of operation that basically
has to do with the singular values of
this matrix right so how do we do that
so the first step is that we have to
figure out a way to map this matrix a
into some unitary you okay this is what
you can call block encoding or have a
kyurem efficient representation you
somehow map this a to this you so that
somehow the spectra of these two are
related
okay and you know how to implement this
you right this is the first thing that
you have to figure out right so what you
need is to need to know how to map the
eigenvector from one to the other like
there is you can map them and you know
how to you know how to map them and the
second is that there is some function
where the the for example the singular
value of a is some function of the eigen
value of U and you know this function
you really mean something different than
what was in Roman stuff is it because in
his talk the religion was okay let's
plant a as a corner of you when actually
there was no relationship at all between
the ions by user and I came back to the
view and those of terraces that it's not
relationship to the relation it was that
you know if you project actually this
factory is not no I don't think that
this is it's not clear that if you do a
block encoding that this will be true
the only the only okay to me the only
way I know how to figure out what
unitary to put there so that is in this
corner great is in a way where the
spectra are also you know what is the
relation of the spectra like what what
Robin was talking to is mostly the
second step like if you know how this
you if you if you have an efficient way
of putting this a this is in this corner
for example okay
then what do you do then you do some way
of figuring out the eigenvalues of this
unitary right and then you go back to
the singular values of a right this is
let me know try to explain what Robin
was saying but let me try to guess so
what I want to say that okay
I'm not saying that this is the only way
but the way that I know how to map this
a to is unitary you is to basically look
at this at this and this quantum works
that kind of gives you one way of
figuring out at you that is related to
this matrix a ok if you figure out a way
of writing a divided by some factor as
the Hannibal product of two matrices and
these matrices have some nice properties
then you can define whoops sorry you can
define a unitary which is kind of this
product of these two deflections and
somehow the the spectrum of the eigen
value the sorry the singular values of
these are related to the eigen value so
that okay so this was how we got the
algorithmic a you have this matrix a I
have to figure out a unitary where
if I do basically phase estimation err
this unitary this will basically tell me
something about the singular values of
the matrix a okay so here is the second
step where you don't have to do this
face estimation on you so you don't need
to actually estimate the phase the
dragon values of you but you can do
something more clever which is either
this linear combination of unit that is
a discretization that you know you have
the lot so I don't want to repeat myself
so this way you're getting this lot 1
over epsilon as a factor on your what
you do is that you don't you have this
you once you have this you then one
thing to do is to do phase estimation or
on you write so this kind of multiplies
the cost of applying you buy a 1 over
epsilon the the fancier thing to do is
to actually use this u in a circuit
where you only use it log 1 over epsilon
and still be able to compute some
function of the singular values of a
that you want okay all right and some
and then there is also a third step with
this kind of an amplitude amplification
step or a variable time objectification
that kind of gives you another factor in
your running time which has to do with
this minimum eigen value of or singular
value of this matrix which is this kappa
this condition number okay so basically
your running time has this three kind of
components has the condition number
which depend basically is the maximum or
the minimum singular value of a you have
this mu and this mute depends on how
well you manage to get this
decomposition okay and we have different
decompositions will give you a different
new so for example new could be the
Frobenius norm of the matrix or could be
the maximum l1 norm of roar of a column
of the matrix okay and you have a lot 1
over epsilon which comes from from from
the no discretization techniques right
so if you need to to have these
operations up to epsilon then you need
to have this log called poly log 1 over
epsilon overhead ok ok so I guess we are
kind of ok with this factor here the log
1 over Epsilon because this kind of
techniques were very powerful the
I see you and the cubed ization it's
still not clear what is the right
parameter to put here so this is what I
wanted to actually say that we know how
to deal with the error but we know how
to deal with the error after we find the
unitary that kind of relates with your
matrix a so it's not clear what is the
best way of finding this unitary and
what what this should be right so the
way we've done it so far is by using
some quantum works that we kind of that
Andrew and other people have used before
and using a data structure for the
Khurram to actually make this unitary
implementable and efficient okay but
there could be better ways of actually
doing this and this will kind of reduce
the running time of your linear time
solver your linear system solver or of
any of these linear algebra stuff okay
good so any questions about this I just
want to make sure that there is a step
before you start doing distribute
ization thing which is actually finding
this unitary or finding the way of
embedding this matrix a onto the left
corner of your thing and this also plays
a role on your running time right so to
me the way that I see the cubed ization
is that once you know how to do that
then you don't have to worry about your
errors because there are very good
efficient ways of getting only a lot 1
over epsilon your running time if you
want error epsilon okay
one way to see it is that what is the
best new that I can put here so that I
can find to mate which is pnq says that
the hydaburg product of P and Q gives
you this a right you need you need some
properties of P and Q you need you need
the the rows of P the l2 norm of the
rows of P to be less than 1 and the
columns of Q to be less than 1 okay
this basically relates to quantum walks
so we know how to put we know how to put
better things that what I said we know
how to put for example the spectral norm
of the absolute value of the matrix but
what I need extra which is why it's not
such a clean problem is that I also need
to be able to implement this P and Q in
this kind of Purim model meaning that I
only have one pass over the matrix I can
store somehow the things only with poly
log overhead and then I need to be able
to actually implement this this unitary
right for example I don't know how to do
the best work that we know because it
kind of you need to know the top
eigenvector of the matrix before you
actually start doing the book but I
don't know the top eigenvector of the
matrix
somehow right so I don't know what is
the right answer here right somehow
right but then it's not clear that this
is the only way to implement this you
there might be other ways of putting a
into the left corner of you that don't
have to go through quantum works so I
agree with you that if you if you stick
with the quantum works then we kind of
know what the quantum works do so then
the question is can implement the best
one to work with a data structure on the
other hand there could be other ways of
doing this this mapping of the a to the
you that kind of don't go through this
right so that's why it's not clear what
you need to do okay
good so now I will start talking about
classification in because what I really
wanted to understand is whether this
kind of algorithms we really work on
real data so I I needed to find the
problem that it's kind of easy to
benchmark so this is kind of
classification and what we did is that
we looked at this data set
this data set is basically a bunch of
hundred and digits the question is can I
get a quantum algorithm that has two
properties first that they will give me
good enough accuracy on this and second
that I can actually say something about
the running time not on their asymptotic
but actually trying to see how it will
run on this data like what is the
running time okay good so we had to come
up with with the simplest classification
algorithm we could we could imagine okay
again what I assume is that I have I
have a bunch of points in my cluster
okay
I can have quantum access to these
points like I can create a superposition
of these points then a new point comes
and what I want to see I want to
actually figure out what is the distance
some some sort of distance of my point
to this cluster right because what is my
classifier I look at every cluster I
look at my new point I I compute the
distances to every cluster I find the
minimum and I assign my new point to
that cluster right so this is kind of
the supervised classification thing so
what I needed to do is I did it to find
a simple way of saying what kind of
distance can i compute between a point
and a cluster right so the simplest
thing that we can come up with is this
Frobenius distance which is defined like
this and basically what I wanted to show
you is that basically classification
kind of comes for free if you know how
to create your quantum states right so I
want to say that if you know how to
compute how to create these quantum
states right the classification is
nothing more than that somehow okay so
why this is the case well what you do is
that you create the state which means
that on one you just get the
superposition of your points in your
cluster okay and on 0 you just put your
new point X 0 okay so if you know how to
no the class there is a lot of points
that have labeled the same way like all
the names right so I have all the nines
all the nines are points okay this point
the set of points corresponds to my
cluster which is labeled nine okay so
what I'm saying is that if you are able
to manipulate these points in this
quantum way like making super positions
of points then the only thing you have
to do is basically create the state
which is basically creating the your
points then you just do a hammer on your
first qubit which I presume it's a
simple operation to do and then you just
estimate the probability of getting one
okay you can repeat it you can do um
please notification if you want but they
don't want because I want something
simple you can repeat this experiment
you estimate what is the probability
that you get one this is exactly this
distance okay so basically we define the
distance because this is what we could
do but this doesn't mean that this is a
good classification algorithm so the
first thing you have to show is that if
you define classification like this that
this actually gives you good results
somehow right so
and then I guess you do it for every
cluster and then you assign x0 to the
closest cluster right okay so the first
two d'marco won't make is exactly what I
said before is that basically the
classification algorithm that apart from
this extra Haddam are then actually been
able to create the states so so I assume
that you have the classical classical
vectors vectors and then here these are
the matrices now I just take the
Frobenius distance of the two matrices
so my first matrix are all the points of
the cluster I define this as my X K
matrix and my x0 matrix is not a matrix
it's just the same X 0 vector many times
is the new point that you want to
classify right so I'm saying look at the
matrix that corresponds to your cluster
look at your new point I look at the
Frobenius distance of these two things
okay
normalized rank and I'm claiming that
and I'm just saying this is the distance
I'm going to to compute okay it might be
a good thing to cluster it might be a
bad thing to cluster somehow right but
the first thing I wanted to say is that
if you know how to create the states
then you do have the measure and this
gives you the distance okay
the probability so it's not any more
difficult than actually clustering
actually creating the states okay and
the second remark is that the accuracy
that you get with this with this
clustering is not different than what
you would get with like the best kind of
classical clustering algorithm or like
closest the K nearest neighbors or
Gaussian classifier or things like that
okay okay good
are we done no we're not done because if
you try to classify this data
with this classifier or even with
classical classifiers like k nearest
neighbor or anything like that
you only get something like 67% of
accuracy ok so that's not good right and
the reason it's not good is that
basically these this if you just naively
take these digits and code and take them
into into vectors then this this these
vectors are not cluster in that space
very well right so first you have to
move these vectors into a different
space where they're very good well they
are clustered and there is where you do
your classification what your clustering
algorithm okay so this is how classical
people also get good classification for
this thing the first thing that they do
is not just run their classifier yeah
not before you do the processing so I
will show you yes yes you can get even
more you can get 98 99 percent with with
classical language but not on the raw
data so all I'm saying here is that if I
take this this no I don't know
so
so the thing you do if you want to have
a better classification can there many
things you do you can also do neural
networks and stuff but if you want to do
this type of classification the first
thing you have to do is basically take
your points and somehow move them into a
different space where the clustering is
much better okay so this is kind of a
classical algorithm to do that which is
that which is called slow feature
analysis okay maybe I don't want to
explain but the region store feature
analysis is there is trying to explain
the following like if you're watching a
tennis game these images are very
different and you see many different
images one after the other right like
this image is not really the same as
this image but somehow your brain can
very easily say what this is this is
Federer you know playing tennis somehow
so you have two different things one is
that the images that your eye sees are
very many and very different very fast
right like if I move like this
everything has moved but somehow my
brain and understand understands what I
see right so they try to mimic this kind
of process and they say that look what
we will do is that we will look at these
images of the series and I will look at
the derivative of the series meaning I'm
taking the the differences between
consecutive images and then what I will
try to figure out is what doesn't change
in the derivative right what is the
thing that kind of I keep so I can make
I can see that this is federal running
somehow right so if you want to see it
from a mathematical point of view
basically what you do is that you look
at the derivative matrix you have to do
a PCA on the derivative covariance
matrix and then what you keep is the
lowest eigen eigen spectrum like the K
lowest eigen vectors and these are kind
of the features that kind of move the
slowest from one nine to the other and
this is kind of where you project your
vectors okay don't really ask me why it
works I mean you know
what is alignment what do you mean yes
you will be terrible if you just try to
classify before you do something like
that yes yes yes but this is if you look
at at the derivative I'm taking the
derivative matrix I'm doing SVD on the
derivative matrix and I'm que I'm taking
the lowest eigen vector which is kind of
what keeps kind of the thing that hasn't
changed between the two you're thinking
of pixels yes it's not that okay so they
don't call it alignment but what you
have to take into account is the
correlations between the pixels as well
so there is another step that the kind
of skip which is before this which is
you don't look only at pixels but you
only look at pairs or triplets of of
pixels and this is the matrix that you
actually look at the derivative of and
there things are better because you know
that the nine has to be a circular thing
so you're going to find many things
where here there is a white and then
there is a black on top and a block
below okay
yes so this is 700 or mariano 784 pixels
with a black and white somehow so the
raw vector is just a vector of 700 0 1
bits somehow and then when you
pre-process it you do many things and it
becomes like a vector in some much
bigger dimension so for example you also
look at at pairs and this is a different
dimension and things like okay I'm yes
so I think one point to get is that if
you really want to make something work
in practice is not easy it's not just
figuring out the theoretical algorithm
and say I'm done it should work right
there's a lot of things to be done if
you really want to have something work
in practice and I really want to try in
the like two minutes to mean it's
fantastic to actually show you what we
did okay so the first thing we had to do
was also come up with a plan to way of
doing this this part and this is okay
because it's basically again linear
algebra you have to do some matrix
multiplications matrix inversions some
projection on the eigenspace and this
kind of we know how to do okay and the
important thing here to notice one cool
thing is that if you do a quantum thing
like this what you get as I said is not
the classical vector projected into the
space but the quantum state that
corresponds to this vector right but if
you look at the classification we did
before I didn't need the classical
description of the state I just needed
to have the quantum superposition of
these states so it's it's fine for me if
the output of this is a quantum state
and not the classical answer so I only
do this to get a quantum answer out of
this linear algebra thinks this is good
enough for me to do the classification
algorithm afterwards I don't have to do
tomography on this thing get the
classical vector and then classify the
classical vectors okay so this is also
an important thing okay so the
classifier is very simple I look at my
matrix first I do this Q sfa I project
it into some other space and then I use
this quantum states that correspond to
this and I do my my my classification
using the classifier okay what accuracy
do I get where we got 98.5 it's kind of
this
I'll go the same accuracy they get with
classical SFA and k-nearest neighbor for
example okay and how did we get this
accuracy
well this data set has also 10000 digits
which are not labeled and then you have
to run your algorithm on this and see if
you get the correct label or not okay so
this is how the accuracy comes okay and
what is the running time so here you
gonna scream because this is not very
asymptotic but okay so classically what
you can do is something of the order and
this square like n is the number of
points that you have so roughly we have
10 to the 5 points and D Square D is the
dimension not the initial dimension of
the thing but the final dimension that
you get after you do your pre-processing
and then your dimensionality reduction
you get some dimension here D usually
these the one that gives you this
classically is like 10 to the 4 so you
have 10 to the 5 points 10 to the fourth
dimension its point if you have a
running time or roughly these you get
something like 10 to the 13 it's like
one hour on a on a good computer to do
this classically so what is the quantum
time well the quantum time depends on
many things right so what we know is
that poly logarithmic on N and D that's
very good so I can stop here and I say I
have an exponentially better quantum
algorithm and you know I can publish a
paper but that's not what I wanted to do
I want it to really look at everything
that goes into the running time and at
least figure out what are these things
like for this data set I'm not gonna get
the proof that if I change my data it
will work but at least I want to get
some evidence of whether in practice
this thing could possibly work right so
if this doesn't work then I know that
it's not going to work if this works
then there's some chance that maybe the
actually will work ok yeah
so I'm putting an epsilon error on the
on the singular value estimation and
this kind of carries on on the
projection as well and the error I am
putting a Gaussian around the the
singular value so I'm doing this on a
perfect computer with logical qubits I
don't even know if that works so I'm not
claiming that this works in a noisy
computer I don't even know if it works
in a fantastic computer so this is the
epsilon that I can assume that my my
phase estimation can have and still get
98.5 accuracy I had to take epsilon to
be 10 to the minus 7 which means that if
I used my previous algorithm I get 10 to
the 7 running time just from the epsilon
but due to the new very cool algorithms
I only have a lot 1 over epsilon so I'm
ok with that
ok this theta and Delta are the
parameters I need for the projection on
the eigenvalues and basically these are
like 10 to the minus 2 okay and what I
really cared is about this cap and this
mu because this Kappa mu depend on the
matrix right so okay so if you put
everything together I get 10 to the 7 so
you I don't want to keep on that but I
want to show you how this parameters
change with the dimension okay so to me
this is the more important so here okay
so now you know why I I'm not very used
in putting diagrams in my talk so you
can't see them very well but what is
this this is the parameter mu or the
matrix that could be the Frobenius norm
it could be the sparsity or it could be
the l1 norm
okay and this is how it changed changes
when I increase the number of point and
this is how it changes when I increase
the number of dimension so to me this
kind of shows that if I increase the
dimension a little bit more this thing
is not going to blow up so the proof but
you can see how it changes and also you
can see the difference between if I use
the sparsity I would get the pen to the
4 if I use the Frobenius norm I get 250
and if I use the l1 norm which is the
new linear algebra thing that we did for
the gradient descent
eight like from the beginning to the end
and kind of similar here okay so I want
to show just that you have to really
tweak your algorithm to figure out what
is the right algorithm to get but
somehow you could safely expect that
this parameter here is not going to blow
up with the dimension okay and this is
the same for the kappa the kappa is
worse than than you
so here it's okay because it actually
drops instead of going when you increase
then but here kind of yeah it kind of
plateaus a little bit here so so maybe
for their accommodation systems but for
this I don't know what would be the
problem but I can come up with okay I
can come up with okay
so basically what I wanted to show is
that there is some hope when maybe you
can claim that there is some evidence
that quantum classification Alchemist
can handle bigger dimension and to me
this is the important I don't care about
the faster algorithm I get the algorithm
that can get better accuracy running one
hour on a HPC machine which means that I
can increase the dimension of the points
hence I will get more accurate and the
running time is not going to kill me
because it doesn't scale as badly with
this dimension as the classical one
which is cubic on the dimension okay why
because this poly log on the dimension
is poly log and these guys for this
particular thing they don't really blow
up yeah
there isn't necessarily a single
classical analog for many of these
methods one of the things so I was kind
of wondering what would you expect the
comparison between this would be if you
were to take a look at stochastic
methods for figuring out the variance
because those necessarily depend on yeah
so so you mean on the running time or on
the accuracy so what we looked at we
looked at Alcor is that kind of at least
can get you 98 1989 their language that
can get you 99.5 using neural networks
and stuff I don't know how to do
anything on that side okay so we looked
at the algorithms that kind of do some
dimensionality reduction and then kind
of classification okay
this algorithm now they can start from
95 up to ninety eight point seven eight
okay and the running time of these so
what I know is that the classical paper
that does classical sfa plus K and n
right he did exactly the same dimension
as us 30 dimension 35 with polynomial
expansion of 3 and it takes one hour on
the on the same machine yes the problem
is not the KNN like it's not on the
classification that is your your problem
it's on the dimensionality reduction
your time your time bottleneck is not
the classification so what you need is
better algorithms for pca basically and
we kind of use the ones the better ones
that we found around like from from the
classical machine learning toolkits
basically it could be that there exists
better I mean of course but I'm saying
we used the classical standard library
for doing the the sfa right which
hopefully asymptotically it's that it's
nd square you cannot get and we used one
that people use
and for for the K&N it doesn't matter
you can it's not where you get the 10 to
the 13 somehow okay alright so I get
over the k-means summary can say one
thing okay one thing one thing so okay I
want to say why do I think that maybe
quantum computers could do good stuff
for optimization in machine learning
okay
and it's not because I managed to prove
something or other people prove
something but to me there are two things
first of all is that it's not a
worst-case thing like you have these
matrices you need to do some linear
algebra on these matrices you're not
trying to see what is the worst case
scenario that will happen with your
matrices right and usually these
matrices have some some structure in the
sense that it's not maybe the structure
is not obvious when you look at it like
when you look at the pixels but what you
do in machine learning is that you
figure out how to map this thing into a
space where there is some structure like
if you ought to cluster it better be
that your data is class terrible if it's
not then there's nothing you can do if
you just get uniform points in the space
no matter how you cluster it's not going
to be a very good cluster somehow right
you need you want to be able to cluster
when your data can be clustered right
data that can be clustered is low rank
for example right if you have ten
clusters it means you can come up with a
low-rank approximation of roughly pen
that can actually so what I'm saying is
that there is a lot of you are trying to
get something out of your data some
structure that exists and many times the
structure kind of translates to think
that you can use to have good quantum
algorithms for example good low rank
approximations and the second denies
really finished is that these arguments
are very robust to errors you have this
log 1 over Epsilon kind of dependence on
the error and second of all ml is not an
exact science you don't really want to
find an exact solution you want to go
close to a solution when you're doing
gradient descent I don't care if I
really go to the best way I can go there
I can go a little bit to the left a
little bit to the right I'm still gonna
go close to my to my local minimum after
a few steps right ok so that's it sorry
I'm done yes we're way over time so yeah
sorry yeah
no please so I think the the best
classical approach to the handwritten
digits problem convolutional networks
yes and you said to you are extracting
features from the from the pictures so
the pre-processing what I do as the
pre-processing is exactly what the
classical people were doing when they
were using this method which is you do a
PCA in the beginning then you do a
polynomial expansion to get the
correlations between the pixels and then
you look at the column then you look at
the derivatives and take the smaller
ones I don't know exactly how then the
neural networks work but you write that
if you want to go to 99.5 accuracy then
the ways that people do it is by neural
networks and I don't know I don't know
how to do quantum ural networks I also
don't think that we know as the
community how to do quantum Mira
networks but that's different
would be possible to simulate your
conten ovaries and with a little bit of
people are as emotional schema stimulate
near-term
well the problem is that the best thing
you can simulate is like 40 cubits or 70
if you you know something within 40 and
70 maybe yes so you would need to really
write it down or but my dimension is is
10 to the 4 10 20 to the 4 is 2 to the
thing it could be it could be I don't
know it could be yes what we did in the
simulation is that we simulated the
classical the classical linear algebra
that the algorithm does including the
errors of the of the quantum procedure
or perfect qubits
[Applause]